Hello everybody my name is Markiplier,
and welcome to the personality test!
Now if you know there are certain, like...
categories of personality that can be
divided into certain individual...
qualities. Some are opposing some are...
complementary to each other and each of...
them outlines into these four...
overarching categories each with four...
subcategories. Now this is not fact...
this is obviously an idea. It's the theory of...
how to categorize people personalities...
but at the same time everybody's...
personality is going to be slightly...
different from person to person even if...
they fall in one of these categories...
but.... you guys seem to want to know what kind...
of person I am. So I'm gonna answer this...
quiz for you. And, uh, thankfully there's no...
punishment for getting it wrong and I...
don't have to make a bet! So that's good!
To get started it takes less than 12...
minutes, you got to answer honestly so...
I'm going to be answering as honestly as...
I possibly can and then I'm not gonna do...
any neutral answers there will be no...
neutrality here. It's all going to be one...
hundred percent me and my test. Number one!
You find it difficult to introduce...
yourself to other people. Does "Hello...
everybody!" when I shout it to the entire...
Internet count as introducing myself?
Because I'm pretty sure I got that down...
on lock. Please don't show how many times...
I have to redo my intros. "Hello...
everybody." "Hello everybody." "Hello...
everybody." No, I'm good. You often get so...
lost in thought that you ignore or...
forget your surroundings. Ah, I have a ADD.
Which means that I get a little Spacey...
sometimes, but not so much that I forget...
my surroundings. I have a certain level...
of clutter that I'm comfortable with and...
I think it's only acceptable because I...
forget it, but this doesn't happen too...
often so I'd say it's not neutral just...
yeah, yeah, that's probably right you try...
to respond to your emails as soon as...
possible and cannot stand a messy inbox.
Huh, no, no, no, it'll be weeks before I get
back to some people even my best friends.
I'll text him two days later. So sorry...
I'm bad about that. You find it easy to...
stay relaxed and focused even when...
there's some pressure. Yeah, actually I'm...
great under pressure. I work...
better under pressure than I do without...
pressure, because with pressure I have...
deadlines and with like the eagerness to...
get something done to, like, really show...
that I can do it. That helps me stay...
focused, it is awesome. You do not usually...
initiate conversations. That actually is...
me. I may be bombastic and you know...
exclamatory at times, but I usually don't...
say the first word when it comes to...
people. I don't reach out to my friends...
and text them on a regular basis and...
that maybe you, like me, might be going...
"Whaaat? I can't even fathom that! Checking...
in on your friends is like a regular
thing!" But it's not to me, it's just not...
something I think about. It, it's...
something that takes a lot of, a lot of,...
mental effort to actually do, so I gotta...
go with I agree on that one. I'm an...
introvert, like honestly, I'm an introvert...
so this is me. You rarely do something...
out of sheer curiosity. Oh boy, boy, I-I'm always...
curious. I-I do everything out of sheer...
curiosity. I don't got any other qualities.
You feel superior to other people.  Pfft. What? Me? Huh?What?
Nah! *Gibberish*
whatever, no way, okay. Uh, being organized is...
more important to you than being...
adaptable. Fuu, adaptable is everything.
It's the only thing. It's everything I've...
got. You're usually highly motivated and...
energetic. Yeah, usually. *Bleh* Sorry, burpee, sorry.
Does that count as motivated and...
energetic? Winning the debate matters...
less to you than making sure no one gets...
upset. Ah, I usually like to play the...
mediator in those situations. I love a...
good debate, but usually I don't want to...
like, go out of my way to make sure that...
someone's upset. I mean naturally in...
debate that's gonna happen, so i don't...
mind that but you know, there's always...
common ground to be found so I'd go with...
this disagree: That level of disagree. You...
often feel as if you have to justify...
yourself to other people. No, god, I
never need to justify my actions. I mean...
I may apologize for them and acknowledge...
the weirdness of my actions. But I won't...
justify it. It's just be. Your home and...
work environments are going...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. The...
opposite. No way. Way wrong with that. You do...
not mind being at the center of...
attention. Yeah, I don't mind it, kind of...
happening right now with all of you...
looking at me, incessantly. (O _ O) You consider...
yourself more practical than creative.
*Markiplier noises* I'm pretty practical but at the same...
time what I do is creative. No actually no.
That's complete bollocks I am all...
about practicality. I am, I am minimalist..
to a T, so that's- that probably me. People can...
rarely upset you. Agree, in all honesty...
what gets said to me very rarely upsets...
me. People can say whatever they want...
about me. People can not like my videos...
people can not like me as a person. I...
won't care. I literally couldn't give a...
shit, but if it's my friends talking, it's...
my friends giving me advice, or my...
friends saying something that does hurt...
my feelings. That could hurt my feelings...
because obviously I trust their opinion...
so if they're saying something that's
negative towards me then I'm like well
fuck maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm an
asshole I gotta rethink about this so
that's usually how that goes but it
rarely you try out your travel plans
should usually- woo- does booking a
flight the day prior count as well
thought out? Does packing my suitcase as
I'm running out the door count as well
thought out? I don't think so it is often
difficult for you to relate to other
people's feelings no I am-I'm
excessively empathetic like I I'm really
really, God, I'm really empathetic I may
not like, again, I'm spacey but at the
same time, like, when there's something I
feel for, like, I really feel for. And your
mood can change very quickly. Mm, nah. It usually,
easily, takes a lot to get me from A to B
so, oh, disagree sorry. In a discussion truth
should be more important than people's
sensitivities. Oh, God, yeah. Truth in all
things truth. Truth matters every- above
everything. You rarely worry about how
your actions affect other people. No, I
worry. I worry a lot about what I do and
how they affect people. Yeah, I gotta go
with disagree on that one. Your work
style is closer to random energy spikes
than a methodical- Yeah, yeah that's the
one. That's the randomness and the energy
that's me. You're often envious of others.
You're of- You're-You're noften nenvious of nothers.
Um, not really, no. I'm pretty
happy where I am. I'm pretty happy with
what I have. I'm pretty happy with
who I am. So, I don't find the purpose in
being envious of other people. Like, I got
what I got and I'm lucky to have it. So,
and everyone else has what they have and
they may have more or less but you know
I'm content with what I got and who I am.
An interesting book or video game is often
better than as a so- Oh, fuck yeah. Being able to
develop a plan and stick to it is the
most important part of every project. Yes.
this is something that I've actually
learned. Recently. Because it used to be I
appreciate improvisation above anything
else and I love improv comedy and I love
making stuff up on the fly but also I've
learned that the- the- the better part of
making a project come true is having a
nice plan so I'm going to go with it's
against my nature but I'm learning so
I'll go with this little squid right
there you rarely get a carried away by
fantasies and ideas- Uh, nah. I idea and
fantasize all the time. You often find
yourself lost in thought when you're
walking nature- Oh, hell yeah. If someone
does not respond to your email quickly
you start worrying if you said something
wrong. Nah, I never say anything wrong
what could I say? It's me they're talking
to. How bad could it possibly be? *More Markiplier noises* No, I
I just I assume they're like me and
don't get back to people. As a parent you
would rather your child grow up kind
than smart. Ooh, does it have to be a choice? I
want him to be smart, I guess, but kind is
good too. But what if they're an evil
genius? That might be it might be kind of
cool. Maybe. That's a dumb question. That's
a dumb question. *Markiplier noises ftw*
the way I see it, my way too smart my way
through it is that if they are- they are
smart maybe they'd figure out being kind
all on their own. I don't know I'm assuming
this mean they're either smart and an
asshole or kind and kind of dumb. I'll go
smart yeah I'd rather see smart. You do
not let other people influence your
actions I'm pretty. Bullheaded I will
readily admit I am bull headed to a T.
It's like I, uh, I- I have an idea and I
want to do that and I want to commit to
it and it's hard for me to deviate from
that. Buuut, I'm learning there's no way I can
convince that learning. Like, I don't know
in a grand scheme of things I'm pretty
steadfast in what I want to do so if I
was being honest to the quiz and honest
who i am and even though I've learned to
appreciate the input of others like I'm
confident in in my actions so that's
that's me your dreams tend to focus on
real word of- world and its events yeah
pretty much it's never really really
fantasy stuff except for the nightmares
those are I guess those are real world
stuff anyway it does not take you much
time to start getting involved in social- *Gibberish*
No. You're more of a natural improviser
than a careful planner. Yep. Your emotions
control you more than you control them
Yeah, no. You enjoy going to social events
that involve dress up or role play
activities I've never done that in my
life. I've never gone to a roleplay
social dress up orgy. No, that's not
something I've done. But I wanna! That
sounds awesome! Why wouldn't I do that? I
love it, There was one time when we were
having a Halloween party back in college
and I was the only one that dressed up
don't know what kind of Halloween party
that everybody goes to that they don't dress
up so I was just it's fucking when the
Dark Knight was released and I was the
only one in a- in the- in the Joker, uh
in the nurse costume because everyone
was the Joker that year... Anyway it's not
important. You often spend time exploring
unrealistic and impracti- You know, yeah I'm
gonna go back to that story because it
was really funny because I was, uh, I was
carrying in a box of beer or something
into, uh, into my friends house and I was
knocking on the back door I was like
they were all in there and I was like
knock knock hey my arms full, can you open the door?
I can't do it and they were just
all staring me like (o.o) because the fucking
Joker was at their back door and they
didn't know it's me and none of them
had dressed up so it just looked like
there was a freak as the joker trying to get
into their little party and then my
friends finally let me in it made fun of
me literally all night and that was- that was
good times, that was good times, that was good times... You
often spend time exploring unrealistic
and impractical yet intriguing ideas
*Markiplier "huh!"* yeah I guess yeah I'm all for a good
impractical thing so I don't know why
not, that sounds good to me. You would rather
improvise than spend time coming up with
a detailed plan wasn't it that's a
question that's the same question that's
the same question. You are a relatively
reserved and quiet person. Actually this
is true. My base nature I've learned to
like a- like a lot of things I've
learned to come out a shell but when it
comes down to the base person underneath
like I'm actually very reserved I'm very
quiet I like my peace and calm I like I
I'm not shouting 24-7 so I completely
agree if you had a business you would
find it very difficult to fire loyal
but under-performing employees. Yeah, I
would actually. God, I would- because i have a
business technically I have employees so
it's yeah I just I don't think I could
do that. You often contemplate the
reasons for human existence. Nah, I don't
really I don't think it matters like I
well I mean like it matters in the grand
scheme of things but to me my personal
experience in this world like it'll
carry on whether I know the answer or
not like whether I have an answer
doesn't change the fact that I'm here
still constrained by the rules. You know
what I mean? The rules of the universe and
you can bend the rules and maybe we can
come up with technology to change the
rules but until that point comes, why
bother worrying about it? I mean sure
pursue the truth. Pursue the truth in all
things. Find out the reason, if you really
can find out the reason. But
in the meantime don't let it give you an
existential crisis. Logic is usually more
important than heart when it comes to
making important decisions. Agree! Keeping
your options open is more important than
having a to-do list. Agree! If your friend
is sad about something you are more
likely to offer emotional support than
suggest a way to deal with the problem
Uh, no. I'm a fixer. I'm a fixer. I like
fixing things- I mean I'm there for
emotional support but I'm a fixer. I'm one
hundred percent a fixer. You rarely feel-
feel insecure. Yeah, i'm pretty confident in me. You have no
difficulty coming up with a personal
time- *Markiplier noises* Being right is more
important than being cooperative when it
comes to teamwork no cooperate you think
that everybody's view should be
respected regardless of whether they are
supported by facts or not nope facts
matter you feel more energetic after
spending time with a group of people oh
that's like the basis of my introversion
like I i cannot i can't get energy from
other people i can't i get energy from
being by myself and alone and doing my
own things with my own thoughts I have
to I have to be there you really miss
later things agree you see yourself as a
very emotionally stable agree your mind
is always buzzing with unexplored ideas
and plans agree you would not call
yourself a dreamer I'm a dreamer I'm a
dreamer I'm definitely a dreamer I I
very lofty goals and lofty things that I
want to accomplish in life and lock the
ideas for the world that I'm a dream you
usually find it difficult to relax when
talking in front of many people know
oddly enough even though I'm an
introvert I'm very good at talking I am
ludicrously good at talking I'm great in
social situations when I put my mind to
it but it's not my base nature but oddly
enough being on stage and talking in
front of a whole crowd of people I
actually find enjoyable like I don't
know what it is it I think it's just a
difference between talking to a whole
bunch of people and then talking to
people on an individual level when I
have to talk to people and get no I'm
good at that but it's not my favorite
thing to do you know I love being in on
stage and I love making videos knowing
that there's a whole bunch of people
watching like I get energy from that I
really do I love it but it's like the
interpersonal
stuff like that that's where my
introverted nature comes to life like
that's really where it is it's not like
I don't want to do it I want to meet
people I want to do that I want to meet
you guys on an individual level but when
it comes to that I don't get energy from
it I just don't it has to i have to
spend energy to do that and i think
that's the key difference in an
introvert and extrovert but also
speaking in front of people is something
that comes very natural to me and I
enjoy it a great deal so uh no I'm good
at that I know I don't find it never
journals begin you rely more on your
experience in your imagination not it
doesn't matter if you have experience
because if you can imagine yourself
where you want to be then at least you
have a road to get there and then your
willpower can take you the rest of the
way so I don't have a lot of experience
in a lot of things I do but I I believe
that I can and sometimes that's all you
need you worry too much about what other
people they can think whatever they want
a thing who cares if the room is full
you stay closer to the walls avoiding
the center I usually just find wherever
there's a comfortable seat depends on
the room too so let's imagine some room
like a house party there's a bunch of
people everywhere but there's no
furniture let's just make that
assumption in this weird imagination
world that is my house and then oh I
actually actually know this weird this
is made me realize I like standing in
social situations I'm a stander so I
like standing but not against the wall I
like standing let right in the middle
and it's not for any like sake of being
the center of attention I just like
standing where there's the most space
and i will pick that space and whether
that's the center of the wall i have no
idea so I disagree on this you have a
tendency to procrastinate until it's not
attend to every
you feel very anxious in stressful
situations now again great in stressful
situations I love it I love being
interesting situations it motivates me
to no end you believe that it's more
rewarding to be liked by others than to
be powerful that's a good question
because I believe powerful in the sense
what does that even mean but i'm going
to assume that means influential or you
know can command respect or something to
that effect now you can you can have
power and you can be liked but i'm
assuming this means that you have power
and you're not like or your liked and
have no power so in my all honest like
state I don't really mind if people
don't like me like I get that because I
like me I like I like Who I am and I
like what I'm doing and sometimes I get
bogged down and I gets a tonight
question where I'm going but that's only
because I'm reevaluating and looking in
on myself and seeing if I'm in the place
I want to be and if I'm not I change
that so i guess i would have to buy my
nature say that I find it's more
rewarding to be powerful I guess not
that I craved power but just because the
opposite the answer isn't true so you've
always been interested in unconventional
and ambiguous things EG in books art or
movies wait that's not unconventional
that's not unconventional I mean yeah I
like me some good books and movies and I
can appreciate me some good art modern
art I'm on the fence of but you know I
can appreciate it and I guess I
gravitate towards those things and video
games with the medium you know yeah I
guess I could do yeah I could say that
if you call those on and conventional
and ambiguous you often take the
initiative in social situations ah again
here's where my weird nature comes in
because if it's a social situation where
i need to take the initiative like a
convention or a meet-and-greet with you
guys or a panel i gladly take center
stage I will do that and I'll be there
I'll make introductions if I'm in a
meeting I'm gonna be the first one to
try to remember everybody's name shake
everyone's hand because i like giving
off a good impression
and that overcomes my nature of wanting
to be an entry so like my desires / take
certain nature's and each one will play
a different role in different situations
so i would i would take the innocent and
with that that is the last question and
therefore we're ready for an answer you
all ready to be astonished by what is in
the super scientific survey of epic
proportions that here we go BAM I'm a
debater I'm a debater deeper-dirt-did
but do I don't know what that means I'm
a debater which is an entp dash a UH it
means that I'm it I like this because i
like this because it ranks your
extraversion and introversion because i
think we all need certain levels of
social situations we need certain levels
of isolation time and so you know they
vary from person person to person we
direct our mental energy towards the
intuitive or the observance so I I get a
lot of my energy I guess from my mind I
come up with my ideas and then my nature
is very much thinking but still feeling
like I do feel like it's not like I am
completely numb to what other people
think or like what I feel because
obviously you guys know this from all
the crying videos I have put on a much
animal here but you know I'm very I'm
very logically organ in it I've always
said tactics yep I'm bad at planning and
pretty sure that's all that what it is I
don't plan I just make it up as I go
along and then identity I'm a hundred
percent assertive a hundred brute I'm a
hundred percent a kid i'm ninety seven
percent i don't have a plan ninety
ninety ninety seven percent of the time
but I'm a hundred percent of sort of how
dare you I let me point out why you're
wrong about that I am the least
observers laughs yeah they're right I
don't know what that means anything oh
here we go follow the path of the unsafe
independent thinker expose your ideas to
the dangers of controversy speak our
mind and fear less the label of crackpot
than the stigma of conformity non issues
that seem important to you stand up and
be counted
at any cost I don't know what this means
anyway the ultimate devil's advocate oh
boy they're having on the process of
shedding arguments into belief in
letting the ribbons drift in this win
for all the sea an object's to position
arises with debaters as their
uncompromising Lee honest but will argue
tirelessly for something they don't
actually build what stepping into
another shoes to argue truth from
another perspective oh okay I get it so
that just means that I that debaters not
me particularly would see the problem
from another perspective even if even if
i'm wrong and that's true like even if
i'm wrong i want to make sure you know i
like even if i think i'm right and i'm
actually wrong I want to make sure that
I'm right and I would you know see the
counter point of that there are no rules
here we're trying to accomplish
something taking a certain pleasure in
being the underdog debaters enjoy the
mental exercise in questioning the
prevailing mode of thought making them
irreplaceable and reworking existing
systems are shaking things up and
pushing them in New clever new
directions however they'll be miserable
managing the day-to-day mechanics of
actually implementing their suggestions
ah that me that sounds like me maybe
okay all right then what's my with my
weird al Adam Savage Sarah Silverman
Mark Twain great Tom Hanks cool this is
a whole grab bag all the Joker it's all
fate it makes sense that's it look it
the I was the joke of Halloween there is
kind of fuck you know what the fuck're
the test for these not real characters
fuck does that mean I don't know hey but
hey I'm with the Joker I guess so that's
good it's my strengths and weaknesses
with L like ah cool all right cool
what's my weaknesses argumentative oh
maybe I don't dare you i'm not all
humanity insensitive god no I'm not
I'm a little insensitive this is a bunch
of bullshit this is a load of garbo
that's it this this is a bunch of
bullshit all right let's see you career
paths if engineers on here I'm gonna be
pissed baby boom bah buh buh buh not
every career allows this level of
unbridled the brain power yeah oh yeah
that's me all right mmm delegate lucky
little bit Goulet bill the conclusion
let's just get a glove get it all out
there debaters intelligence curiosity
and sound reasoning skills are a force
to be reckoned with debaters will always
be able to find just the right argument
the weakest Jenkin now opponents of
armor or the way out of a seemingly
hopeful hopeless situation their
fearsome debate skills and impressive
knowledge allowed to baiters they
overcome many I think this is flattering
me at this point I'm not a hundred
percent sure that this is true here but
whatever I guess yet debaters can be
easily tripped up in areas where careful
and rational thinking is more of a
liability than an asset what I nuh-huh
fuck you take some of this take my entp
guns here and fuck them up your ass
alright anyway I guess I'm all done here
you may have mutter to yourself wow this
is so accurate it's a little creepy or
finally someone understands me how do
they know more more about me than the
people I'm closes too yeah whatever okay
all right you're writing some spots you
wrong and some other spots which is
probably what it don't Pater would say
on un to PA whatever good anyway that's
up me i guess so i don't know if that's
true or not but it is what it says it is
so you want to take this for yourself
again take the results with a grain of
salt like I said in the test I went by
what my base nature is but I've learned
things to escape that and I've changed
over time so if I took this year or if I
took this quiz like five years ago it
probably completely different results
because I wouldn't have had the
experience of being a youtuber and
talking to you guys and learning from
you guys
and getting those experiences in my own
personnel because you know we change
people do people change hopefully for
the better sometimes for the worse but
people change and you can learn
different skills so if I worst answer
this based on what i think i am now it
might be different from what i actually
am and who knows what you actually off a
test isn't going to tell that life
experience going away thank you
everybody so much for watching up with a
link to this quiz down the comments
below description below I was right the
whole time and let me know what you
think let me know what kind of
personality you are I'd love to hear
just in five letters what kind of
personality your boiled down do and
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video